-Thank you for being here.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-And thank you for doing
another talk show after
you already did a talk sho
this morning.
-Oh sure.
-I appreciate
you doing double duty.
-Oh, no problem.
I feel like a cool kid
anytime I get to do anything
that's after 12:00
in the afternoon.
-Yeah, well that's --
Well, thank you
for cool-kidding with us.
And you were also a cool kid
in that you were an intern
at "SNL" when you were
like 19 years old?
-19, 20, yeah.
-Okay, and I was there.
I was in the cast then.
Do you have any memories of me
And I'm hoping...
[ Laughter ]
-I do.
-Okay.
-Yeah, you were
a total gentleman.
-Oh, good, good.
-Very respectful of interns.
-Thank you. There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I remember, one time, I had to,
like, clean up a table,
and there were, like, magazine
all over it,
and they, like,
made me organize it.
And you helped me,
so there you go.
-There you go.
That's incredibly...
-Nice guy, Seth.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-It's such a weird time
in my life,
and it's a thing
that people always ask about
People always want to know
what the experience was like
And I -- You know,
even coming in this building
it's just very nostalgic because
there's a page letting me in
-Yeah, no, and a lot has staye
very much the same,
not just the physical space.
But there are things,
like the page outfit, I don'
think has changed in 50 years.
-They wear the same jacket
-Yeah.
I'm always happy because
it's such a stressful plac
that when I meet people
that used to be interns,
I'm just so afraid that they -
Well, somebody came up
and gave me a piece of bad news,
and I, like, took --
like, I looked at them
and was like, "What?"
So I'm very happy
that I was helping
with magazine assortments
instead.
-Everyone was wonderful.
-Good.
-I don't know if I just, like --
I also, like, you know,
have worked at
a lot of other places
that, like, crazy things happen,
and nothing ever happens to me
And I always wonder if, like
people were so scared of my da
or I just come off
like a tough chick.
I don't know, but I had
a wonderful internship.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
I probably took it out
on one of the interns
that wasn't John McCain's dad,
yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Or John McCain's daughter.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Fixed a lot of problems,
growing up.
-So, I want to ask --
you also had something --
both your parents have bee
impersonated on "SNL,"
and then it happened for you -
Aidy Bryant did you.
-Yeah.
-And what was it like?
I'm guessing maybe
you weren't watching live.
When did you hear that Aid
had done you on the show?
-I was on vacation
with my husband,
and I woke up in the morning
and I had a ton of --
it was like, ding, ding, ding,
ding when I turned on my phone
And it was like, "You're o
'SNL,' you're on 'SNL.'"
And I was like, and then I
brought it up on the computer.
And Aidy and I went
to high school together.
-Which is crazy.
-Xavier College Preparator
in Phoenix.
So there you go. Thank you
So, it's weird to be,
like, have this girl
I went to high school with
impersonate me,
which is amazing.
And she's so talented
and incredible.
And I watched it,
and I thought it was hilarious
And my husband thought
it was hilarious,
except they paint me out
to be an anti-vaxxer,
and he thought that was
the most offensive part.
He was like, "You're
not an anti-vaxxer."
-So, let's use this time
right now
to just say to everyone
that Meghan and I agree
on vaccinating your kids.
-Vaccinate your children.
-There you go.
-Thank you.
-Common ground.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks, guys. [ Chuckles
-You've obviously been
very open and vocal
about the fact
that it is distressing to you,
the fact that not only
did Donald Trump
attack your father in life
he is continuing to attack him
after he passed away.
Are you -- What do you think
If your dad was still around
like, do you think he would be
delighted by the fact
that Donald Trump cannot
shake him from his psyche?
-I mean, when he was alive
he was always like --
I mean, this is
a late night show, right?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So he'd be like,
"I don't give a [Bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, you know,
he just doesn't care
about people attacking him
He had been through so much.
It was very hard
to rattle him in any way.
And it's just strange
that this sort of feud
didn't end when he passed.
-Yeah, historically,
it tends to.
-It should.
[ Laughter ]
But I think it says so muc
about where
the President's head's at.
And the last time he had
attacked my father publicl
on Twitter,
it was the weekend,
and I just remember
when, you know, my life --
when I spend my weekends,
it was with my family
in Arizona,
hiking and cooking and camping
And I wish he would do that with
his family on the weekends
instead of
obsessing over my family.
-Yeah.
-And it's very strange, so..
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think --
-But it makes me,
like, sad for them
that you're not --
Like, life is really short
And I feel it a lot right now,
and I think it's because
my father died
a little over eight months ago
and I just feel every moment
And I think you...
And this is a message
to everybody,
not just the President.
But, like, spend the time of
you have with those you love
because you don't know if you're
going to get a phone call
saying the person you love
the most in the world
has glioblastoma
and has a year to live.
And I know what that looks like,
and I just wish the Presiden
and his family
would, like, really
live in the moment.
And you're President,
and I'm sure
there's a lot of interesting
things to do in the White House,
and spend time with your family.
-Yeah, I will say,
if the other alternative
is camping,
I think he's still going t
tweet about your dad.
[ Laughter ]
-Probably.
-I don't see him going out on --
-You know, obviously,
they had a history
where the President
was very open
about how he felt
about your father.
Your father, in turn, was
very open with how he felt
They were not
fans of each other.
I imagine it must be harde
for your family
with someone like
Senator Lindsey Graham,
who was your father's
incredibly close friend
and now has sort of tied
his fortunes to the President.
Is that a harder thing for
your family to watch happen?
-Well, first, I think
that everyone in the Trump years
sort of has to reconcile
with their conscience
and how -- what role they played
in it on all sides,
because I think that he evokes
the worst in all of us.
That's my just take
on who he is as President.
I think he has ruffled up
a lot of negative things
in a lot of ways on both sides
I think, with --
you know, Lindsey,
I grew up with Lindsey Graham.
I can call him Lindsey.
And I considered him
my father's best friend
and uncle
for a really long time.
And you know, he --
It's hard for me,
and it disappoints me,
but I also understand politics
And I will always love him
and respect him.
But, politically,
I don't understand it,
because I think
the idea probably is
that politically
you sort of have to,
you know, make amends with Trump
in one way or another,
to be politically relevant
and to gain re-election.
But my father was
his biggest enemy,
or, I guess, one of
his political largest enemies,
and he won his re-election
handily in Arizona.
And Arizona,
up until that point,
was a red state.
Now it's switched to purple.
But it is possible.
I just think it --
You have to work harder.
-Yeah.
-And I don't know if politicians
want to do that,
but I'm always
going to love Lindsey.
I'm always going to have
a special place in my heart.
But, you know, it --
Of course, it disappoints me
-Yeah.
-I mean, I think I would b
inhuman if it didn't.
-If you said, "
That's really cool, you be you."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's just --
It's strange, too, because
people know their relationship
I mean, I think probably
most people here know that
and people ask me a lot --
quite a lot.
-I don't think Senator Graha
made any secret of it,
and I think that's why he has to
answer these questions now is,
you know, when you have
a friendship
and you talk a lot about how
much somebody means to you
It's very strange for people
to watch you
sort of reverse course on that
I want to ask about Ilhan Omar
Congresswoman from Minnesota
You know, she was --
You were very vocal
about some of her tweets.
People were upset,
thought it was
anti-Semitic language.
She has since unequivocall
apologized for them.
And then, after that,
there was this tragic synagogu
shooting in California.
And you once again, sort of,
on a Sunday show --
a Sunday news show --
brought up her tweets agai
in the context of that shooting.
-On George Stephanopoulos.
yeah.
And I just wonder, cause I d
think it's fairly dangerous,
and you brought it up afte
Congresswoman Omar
had also had some death threat
against her.
Do you think -- you know,
she's obviously now stated
she needs to be more careful
with her language.
Don't you think other people
who talk about her
need to be a little bit
more thoughtful, as well?
Or do you stand by those
comments of tying her to this --
her rhetoric
to the synagogue shooting?
-I don't think I tied her to i
in particular.
I think that I'm calling out
what I see
as anti-Semitic language.
And when you're talking abou
how hypnotic --
-But even after,
you called it out
after she'd apologized for it.
I do want to establish
the timeline.
-I don't -- I think that
Democrats are hedging on this,
and I think it's very dangerous.
And I think Chuck Schumer and
are in alignment about Israel'
stance in geopolitical politics.
I think it's
of the utmost importance.
And I think she is bringin
her party to the extreme -
extremism on this,
and I think
we have to look to Europe an
what's happening over there.
and that they're -- You know
in the British politics,
anti-Semitism is very common
And I see it happening
over there,
and I worry about it happening
over here.
I stand by every single thin
I've said.
And if that makes me unpopular
in this room
or in front of you, so be it
-Well, I don't...
[ Cheers and applause ]
See, that's a weird thing
that you would take the position
of trying to be unpopular.
Here I am, trying to, you know
find the common ground on this
because I do think one of the --
I think we can both agree --
-Were you bothered
by her language about 9/11
-I thought it was
taken out of context.
And I think, if you
watch that whole speech --
-Would you give President Trum
the same leverage
if he had said the same thing?
-Well, I would say
that Donald Trump
is certainly in no position to
criticize her language on 9/11
based on the things that he'
said about 9/11, right?
-But would you give --
I just think
you have to give people
the same credence,
and I think she's getting
a lot of passes.
-Let me make the clarification
between Donald Trump
and Ilhan Omar, is
one of them has apologized
and said they're going to
try to do better,
and they're going to be educated
by people who know about this.
That's what she said.
And I think she...
You know, it's
an interesting thing,
when we have two Muslim wome
for the first time,
they do have a different
perspective on things.
And I think, when we
talk about the idea
of like, "Let's all try to mee
in the middle on things,"
we have to listen to other
people's perspective.
-Oh, I agree.
I work on "The View"
with Joy Behar every day.
-I listen to other perspective
all the time.
-Is there a way for people
to talk about
differences in Israeli polic
without getting framed
as anti-Semitic language?
-Yeah, I just think
you can't talk
about Jews
hypnotizing the world,
talking about
"all about the Benjamins."
-You do keep bringing up
the two tweets
that she's apologized for,
and I think that's
a little unfair to her,
especially because
we've established --
-Are you her publicist?
-What?
-Are you her press person?
-No, I'm just someone
who cares about the fact
that there's someone out there
who is in a minority, who ha
had death threats against her,
and I think that we should
all use the same language
that you're asking her to be
careful about her language
And I would ask everybody else
to be careful about theirs
-Okay. Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, I'm not sure what --
What would you --
What would make you happy,
coming out of my mouth
right now?
I'm genuinely curious.
-I'm perfectly happy
with everything
that's coming out of your mouth,
and I like that we spent
this time together.
-Okay, you seem a little -
I mean, I think, you know,
my opinions are very strong, and
I think sometimes because --
-That is coming across.
I do want you to know that
-But I'm on a network show
I'm on ABC.
And I think sometimes,
when you're
a hardcore conservative woma
like I am,
I think sometimes it's daunting.
I'm not on Fox News anymore.
I'm on ABC.
I think sometimes my beliefs
even though I do believe
I represent the vast majority of
people in red states,
or at least a lot of women
in the middle of the country
who are pro-life, pro-NRA,
you know, strong foreign policy,
people who believe
in limited and small government,
I think that sometimes
it tends to be jarring
for people to see
someone like me
in mainstream news, not on Fox
-But I think it's good
that you are on mainstream news,
You do have a platform.
I mean, I think
there's this idea
that maybe you're
saying unpopular things,
but certainly ABC thinks
it's worth hearing.
So, you know,
you have a platform,
I have a platform.
I think we're very lucky.
And I think we have to --
-Oh yeah, I'm, like, so lucky.
-Well, we're in agreement
on that, as well.
Vaccinate your kids.
Meghan McCain, everybody.
Thank you so much
for spending time with me.